well you sort of based on me the Eric
cash is a 35 year old maitre d at a Tony
restaurant down there who is one of
three people that get confronted in this
mugging the other two are you young guys
in their early 20s one of them gets
killed the other one is so drunk he
doesn't remember the whole incident and
the thing about Eric cash is that he's
35 and down on the Lower East Side 35
looks like 65 you know it's it's sort of
like you know the tyranny of youth and
the tyranny tyranny of I'll live forever
and anything's possible everything good
will happen to me nothing's bad has ever
happened to me Eric went down to the
lower east side when he was 22 just like
the kids are going down there now and he
became a Maitre D' but it was just a
means to an end he thought someday he
was going to be a working actor he was
going to be a screenwriter or some kind
of writer and maitre d was just you know
to pay the bills until glory happened
well all the hyphens have fallen off
after maitre d he's not nothing's
panning out and he realizes that that's
what he is he's a Maitre D' there's
nothing wrong with being a Maitre D'
unless that's not what you wanted to be
that was just like your your starting
point um the problem and the tournament
for him is that he's surrounded by 22
year olds that were just like him 13
years ago and they're a torment to him
because they all think they're going to
make it they all think they're going to
live forever and what happened when the
murder goes down the police Eric
responds in a way that he's not proud of
he basically runs away he never calls
911 the police got to the scene they
list that talk and Eric and they they
know he's lying he's covering something
and along with two bad eye witnesses
they think they've got the shooter and
so whatever wasn't destroyed in him by
being so close to a death is eviscerated
by the cops over the next eight hours
and
room and by the time the cops are done
with him you can pick him up with a
Dustbuster problem is that once they
realize they made a mistake and they
locked up the wrong guy they realized
he's their only true eyewitness and he
won't cooperate with them he's just been
wrecked what I was writing about was
what would happen to me if I was one of
those kids at 22 which I was and I had a
early publication so I was like 24 when
the wanders was published but Eric cash
would have been made if nothing ever
nothing ever broke for me I don't know
if I would have been a Maitre D' I but I
you know would probably one of a
trillion lawyer somewhere and it's he's
the ghost of Christmas future um you
know there but for the grace of God I'll
never know that first of all I don't I
mean I was an idiot I didn't I wasn't
ambitious i was i was still in school I
was just writing for my writing class
you know and for me but when I had
enough of those stories together and
they went out it was and I heard they
were going to get published it was like
the world's best term paper ever you
know didn't even dawn on me that well
right now you're no longer a writer
you're an author you know it I mean it
honestly if I knew what the odds were if
I knew what I was intending to do a
little more acutely I probably would
have been too psyched out to pursue it I
mean it happened almost in spite of
myself I didn't you know I didn't hustle
in any way and the thing is that when I
was 24 and I was going to 22 23 when I
was going to Columbia the School of the
Arts writing program if the lower east
side was like the way it is now back
then I probably would have crawled on
broken glass to go down there and be in
that neighborhood I mean I would have
loved the playground like that and it
probably also would have been well maybe
not as oblivious as a lot of kids to the
other worlds down there because I come
from a housing project but they I mean I
would pretty much be focused on other
people like me
it was like one big Little Rascals
clubhouse